duck dynasty's Robertson clan has become
Louisiana's de-facto first family
despite patriarch Phil Robertson's
well-known controversial statements to
GQ some secrets still remain tucked away
behind those big bushy beards
let's look past the bird calls and
shotguns and explore the untold truth of
duck dynasty's Robertson family since
her charade Phil Robertson's faith is no
secret but apparently the folks at A&E
thought they could keep it a secret
early on in the show's production
Robertson told sports spectrum in 2013
but during the show the editors would
add some bleeps of the audio to make it
look like the family members were
swearing but he insisted no vulgarity
was used he also alleged that producers
edited out the words in Jesus name
during a family prayer film for the end
of one early episode according to
Robertson they did it because they
didn't want to offend some of the
Muslims or something heavy drinker
before he became vocal about his
religious beliefs bill Robertson was
quite the Hellraiser according to his
wife miss Kay in her book the women of
duck commander
she writes that Phil's drinking cost him
his job as a teacher although what he
taught has never been revealed it's
known that he educated youngsters for
several years and he also holds a
master's degree in education drinking
also eventually cost the bearded
patriarch his subsequent job running a
bar public image
Robertson's alcoholic past has clearly
affected him and his family and alcohol
has continued to have an impact on their
financial bottom line in 2013 son Willie
Robertson launched his brand of duck
commander wine sold online and at the
finest Walmart's for $10 a bottle
according to Fox News the staunchly
anti-drinking Christian group Family
Ministries went on to cancel an
appearance with Willie lucky for the
Robertson's this was only a drop in the
duck calling bucket well bow-bow bow-bow
bow-bow bow-bow bow-bow substance abuse
much like his father JEP Robertson has
had troubles with substance abuse Jeff
told I am second in 2013 that he has a
sordid history with popping pills being
the least of what he did he started
seeing the warning signs of his reckless
lifestyle after one night when he woke
up after driving under the influence
unable to remember where he came from or
where he was going to the
dianna know what I did that night and I
hope I didn't run over somebody huh I
don't know that wasn't enough to get him
to quit but shortly thereafter his
family staged an intervention since then
he stayed on the straight and narrow
doubting Jase they've earned the
admiration of millions for their
supposedly strong faith but the
Robertson's have had a doubting Thomas
in their midst
at least when it comes to their
television endeavors second eldest son
Jason Jason didn't think for a second
that duck dynasty would last one season
let alone lead the flock to the fame and
fortune they perceived what is that
what's in the same it's a big one let's
go stinking he told Fox News Radio I had
this perception of reality shows that
you had to have all this friction and
fits of rage and four-letter words
luckily Jase was wrong an honest mistake
after visiting New York in 2013 Jase
attempted to stay at the Trump
International Hotel but a hotel staffer
booted him out due to his ZZ Top style
beard as Jase explained it the staffer
was very nice who walked me outside
pointed down the road and said good luck
according to people following the
incident the Trump family reached out to
apologize and the Robertsons ended up
hitting it off with Donald Trump jr.
Fame and misery Chase's son Reed
Robertson knows Fame isn't all it's
cracked up to be
as he admitted during the family's
interviews with I am second weeds
newfound fame initially caused his ego
to swell out of control this resulted in
him pushing his friends away from him
both intentionally and unintentionally
Reed's isolation culminated in some
potentially suicidal thoughts he
credited his faith with getting him back
on track and a stern talking-to from his
dad but he told me he said that's the
most selfish thing that you can do
is as leave this world because you can
take it in perfect proposal fan-favorite
Silas Merritt alkyl sy Robertson has
only ever had eyes for one woman his
wife since 1971
Christine Rainey but his long-term
admiration of her isn't necessarily a
good thing before they got married uncle
sy asked for her hand in marriage over
70 times before she answered his Bridal
calls and said yes some people just
don't take no for an answer
give me a thousand dollars we're called
a big wuss what is this extortion there
you got a ban out of chute thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]